[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen was ein bundeshaushalt 300 56,8
milliarden euro über die wir hier
entscheiden was für eine wirtschaftliche
lage in der wir sind rekord sein bei der
beschäftigung prosperierende dynamisch
wachsende staatseinnahmen volle
sozialkassen niedrige zins was für eine
außergewöhnliche ökonomische situation
wie sich mutmaßlich in dieser form
allein aufgrund des demografischen
wandels kein zweites mal wiederholen
wird
und in dieser situation rühmt sich die
koalition der bundesfinanzminister
gestern die bundeskanzlerin heute dass
keine neuen schulden aufgenommen werden
dass eine schwarze oder ich sage besser
dass eine rote null erreicht wird
nachhaltige haushaltspolitik haben sie
falsch verstanden in unsere verfassung
auch es gibt keine pflicht alles geld
auch wirklich auszugeben das ist nicht
verantwortliche finanzpolitik es muss
auch eine gestaltende finanzpolitik
geben wie die möglichkeiten für
investitionen und vor allen dingen für
entlastungen nutzt wenn sie gegeben sind
die weltlage ändert sich die welt lage
ändert sich das wissen wir alle die frau
bundeskanzlerin hat hier eben ja über
einige impressionen gesprochen praxis
die bundesregierung bereitet sich auf
einen harten rexit vor entnehmen wir den
medien leider nicht den antworten auf
große anfragen der fdp
bundestagsfraktion
wir haben immer noch einen schweren
handelskonflikt mit den vereinigten
staaten nicht überall sind für
technologisch spitze ich könnte die
liste weiter fortsetzen
die weltlage ändert sich und die
grundlagen für unseren zukünftigen
wohlstand werden heute gelegt durch
erstens die stärkung der
wettbewerbsfähigkeit wäre das möglich
durch zweiter anstrengungen bei bildung
und forschung drittens bei der
digitalisierung wirklich tempo zu machen
führt ist für eine flexible form
sozialer absicherung die auf dauer
finanzierbar ist und fünfter einen
gestaltenden schritt in ein jahrzehnt
der erneuerung europas niemals wäre es
leichter dass sich unser land neu
erfindet nichts aber passiert es wäre
möglich dass der soli ab 2020 entfällt
wenn jetzt auch das baukindergeld oder
andere subventionen verzichtet wird
es wäre möglich alte schulden zu tilgen
und das risiko steigender zinsen zu
minimieren
wenn jetzt nicht benötigte rücklagen und
sondervermögen aufgelöst werden es wäre
möglich in digitalisierung forschung und
bildung zu investieren wenn unnötige
staatsbeteiligungen die an der telekom
schrittweise aufgelöst werden wir haben
das alles vorgerechnet dass was sie
vorgelegt haben
das ist ein haushalt der verpassten
chance eigentlich muss man schärfer
sagen es ist ein haushalt der
verlässlich verweigerten gestaltung
meine damen und herren
im nächsten jahr im nächsten jahr werden
wir bei steuern und abgaben vize
weltmeister sein
beim fußball sind wir in der vorrunde
ausgeschieden umgekehrt wäre besser
gewesen und mindestens 41 davon trage
die politische verantwortung
so so und im grunde war alles noch im
detail weiter sprechen und die ganzen
punkt könnte man alle vertiefen
aber es macht de facto keinen sinn
wollte hier schon wieder ausschließlich
über migration sprechen
ich glaube dass die menschen im land
dafür auch kein verständnis haben wie
hier argumentiert die hier debattiert
wird
ich glaube dass das die eine chance für
spielen auch für die politische
auseinandersetzung wenn wir uns nur
beschäftigen mit den ritualisierten
empörungen dfd und auch der
ritualisierten antwort darauf
da haben die menschen im land kein
verständnis wir reden wieder nur in
kommunikation die letzte
haushaltsberatung diese es geht um
migration der gaul anzufragen ja was
gefährdet den inneren frieden in unserem
land
diese frage nehme ich gerne auf
natürlich ist der innere frieden unserem
land bedroht ich bestreite nicht dass es
manche gibt sie auf dem linken auge
blind sind
ich denke an die g-20 krawalle bei olaf
scholz in hamburg
ich halte es auch nicht für klug ich
halte es im übrigen auch nicht für klug
das bündnis 90 die grünen in
nordrhein-westfalen ihren parteitag auf
dem widerstands acker auch der autonomen
bahn hambacher forst abhalten
das trägt nicht zur deeskalation bei
aber es geht man es hier
es gibt manche die sind auf dem linken
auge blind
aber wir sind auf dem richtigen auge
blind sie wollen probleme nicht lösen
sondern sie wollen aus problemen
politisches kapital schlagen
sie wollen nicht politik verändern
sondern sie stellen die legitimation
unseres demokratischen systems in frage
und die gewalttaten in chemnitz und
töten
das ist kein anlass für einen rechtsruck
in unserem land sondern für die stärkung
des rechtsstaats und das haben sie nicht
verstanden so selbstverständlich
selbstverständlich haben wir an rumoren
in der gesellschaft davor kann man doch
überhaupt nicht die augen verschließen
das kriegen wir doch alle mit wer augen
hat zu sehen und zu hören bekommt doch
mit welches rumoren ist in der
gesellschaft gibt in den parteien ja die
sammlungsbewegung von frau wagenknecht
warum gibt's die denn weil sie der
internationalistisch aufgestellten linke
nicht mehr vertraut und jetzt eine art
linken populismus will wie wir ihn in
italien beispielsweise im süden auch
gesehen haben also in den parteien
rumort es doch es kann niemand läuft und
das ist ein problem ist nur was trägt
die regierung dazu bei dieses problem
auch tatsächlich zu lösen
wir diskutieren über die aussagen eines
behördenleiters wir diskutieren über die
aussage eines behördenleiters ich frage
mich in einer solchen sensiblen
situation wieso gestattet der
bundesinnenminister einen behördenleiter
überhaupt interviews zu geben wie er
nicht vorher autorisiert
dann lese ich heute morgen auf der dpa
dass herr seehofer sagt ich spreche es
zitaten spreche jedenfalls mit der
bundeskanzlerin weitaus häufiger als mit
herrn maßen
das beruhigt uns nicht das ist ein
merkwürdiges amtsverständnis herr
bundesinnenminister dass sie mit den
behörden
in ihrem zuständigkeitsbereich in dieser
situation nicht einen engen und
intensiven austausch linken
nebenkriegsschauplätze beschäftigen die
uns beschäftigen und die regierung führt
in dieser zeit nicht sie taumelt den
ereignissen hinterher und stolpert über
die eigene füße und das schafft nicht
ein klima des vertrauens
herr seehofer sie haben davon gesprochen
migration sei die mutter aller probleme
so sprach saddam hussein und der
stellvertretende vorsitzende der cdu
armin laschet sagt dass saddam hussein
sprache die sie verwenden
12 34 störrische stilkritik ist mir aber
die substanz dessen was sie gesagt haben
ich halte es sachlich für
verantwortungslos wenn sie pauschal
migration zu einem problem erklären wie
viele beamtinnen und beamte herr
seehofer bei der bayerischen polizei
oder bei der bundespolizei bei der
bundeswehr bei der feuerwehr haben einen
migrationshintergrund wie viele
millionen menschen in deutschland haben
den deutschen pass und einem
migrationshintergrund
was sagt ihnen das herr seehofer was
sagt ihnen das er seehofer wenn die
polizei in niederlassen niedersachsen
wenn die polizei in niedersachsen
gestern eine resolution verabschiedet
und in zurückhaltung bei der wortwahl
empfiehlt denn viele der
polizeibeamtinnen und polizeibeamten mit
migrationshintergrund fühlen sich durch
sie stigmatisiert und diskriminiert so
heißt es in der resolution der
niedersächsischen polizei
herr seehofer nicht migration ist das
problem das problem ist das management
der migration für das ihre partei auch
mitverantwortung trägt seit fünf jahren
mit verantwortung trägt und was ist von
der von der von der von ihnen vom zaun
gebrochen regierungskrise übriggeblieben
rückführungsabkommen mit italien und
spanien die sie selbst als wirkungslos
erklärt haben die bundeskanzlerin hat
vor der sommerpause hier gesprochen über
den mutmaßlichen bin laden leibwächter
samia und dessen abschiebung gefordert
wie sie und dann ist die schwarz-gelbe
nordrhein-westfälische landesregierung
von der bundesregierung im stich
gelassen worden weil sie in tunis die
notwendigen zusicherungen nicht erwürgt
haben damit gerichte auch rechtssicher
diese abschiebung bestätigen können
jetzt gibt es hier vorschläge vorschläge
für ein fachkräfte zuwanderungsgesetz
aber auch das ist doch nebulös und
enthält eben nicht den notwendigen
paradigmenwechsel den wir brauchen
beispielsweise durch ein punktesystem
die grünen blockieren im bundesrat immer
noch die eingruppierung sichere
herkunftsländer im maghreb raum obwohl
sie doch wissen rechtlich dass bei
individueller verfolgung
selbstverständlich der asyl schutz in
deutschland gegeben werden könnte selbst
wenn das sichere herkunftsländer sind
wir dürfen uns doch nicht wundern dass
das klima in unserem land aufgeheizt ist
wenn die politik parteiübergreifend
nicht in der lage ist gemeinsam probleme
zu lösen
und deshalb will ich das gerne hier
erneuern damit wir eben über die anderen
fragen aussprechen
warum verbinden sich die stärksten
parteien der mitte nicht bund und länder
und gemeinden also
herr hofreiter herr hofreiter ich will
gerade einen appell an alle demokraten
machen und sie haben wieder nichts
besseres zu tun als spalterische
parteitaktische parolen in dieses haus
zu rufen vorrunde auch nicht es ist es
kleines ich finde das empörend herr
hofreiter
ich empfinde ihre partei künftig als
empörend ich will hier appellieren dass
wir uns gegen die wahren gegner unserer
freiheitlichen ordnung zusammenschließen
und sie kommen mit ihrer trauma
bearbeitung von jamaika zu wenig
minister geworden sind was ist das
kleine rückgratlosigkeit dieses
fleckchen zu kochen
diese diese kleinteiligkeit werden sie
und herr hofreiter nein herr hofreiter
ich lasse jetzt gar nichts sagen
legen sie doch mal öffentlich aus dem
jamaika gesprächen wenn sie darauf
zurückkommen
legen sie mal da wären sie da bereit
gewesen den man die maghrebstaaten zu
sicheren herkunftsländern zu machen
nein rufen sie das ist doch genau das
problem
wir lösen die probleme nicht und dazu
fordere ich uns auf bundestag bundesrat
lasst uns ein einwanderungs und
integrationskompetenz finden dass wir
das mittel um dieter klein zu machen
jedenfalls jedenfalls wie sie das
versuchen jedenfalls wie sie das
versuchen wird nicht gelingen
da forderte scholz eine rentengarantie
bis 2040 die kein mensch bezahlen kann
und sie sagen sie sagen sie wollen dass
sie wollen diese rentengarantie
damit es in deutschland keinen trump
liegt das heißt mit sozialer absicherung
mit sozialen leistungen populismus
bekämpfen
das konzept wird nicht funktionieren das
beispiel schweden vom wochenende sollte
sie eines besseren belehrt haben und
glauben sie mal 1 so ehrenwert so
ehrenwert das motiv ist die spaltung
zwischen arm und reich zu bekämpfen und
so richtig es ist zielgerichtet gegen
altersarmut vorzugehen
die spaltung der gesellschaft in
diejenigen die für abschottung sind und
für offenheit die gestaltung der
gesellschaft auch in arm und reich eine
solche spaltung bekämpft man nicht indem
man eine neue spaltung 1 führt nämlich
die inzwischen jung und alt und das ist
genau gegenstand ihrer politik und das
was sie schon beschlossen haben die
mitte der gesellschaft da sprechen sie
auch sie frau bundeskanzlerin hiervon
entlastung
arbeitslosenversicherungsbeitrag runter
pflegeversicherungsbeitrag rauf
rentenversicherungsbeitrag kann nicht
singen sondern muss steigen und dann
sprechen sie gegenüber den menschen auch
übrigens den mindestlohn beziehung da
sprechen sie von entlastung die menschen
haben doch das gefühl dass die
lebenswirklichkeit der arbeitenden mitte
von millionen menschen hier im deutschen
bundestag gar nicht ankommt wenn wir in
dieser weise sprechen also eine
wirkliche entlastung ist nötig und
möglich der mieten stopp auch so ein ich
finde untauglicher versuch zu glauben
man könne damit man könne mit populismus
gegen populismus arbeiten der
wissenschaftliche beirat beim
bundeswirtschaftsministerium sagt
mietpreis bremse funktioniert nicht wir
brauchen marktwirtschaftliche anreize
investitionen sinken die baukosten mehr
bauland
richtig so da sagt die politik frau war
ja dass das sei alles alles unsinn
wo ist noch mal und noch mal das
sturmgeschütz der sozialen
marktwirtschaft der
bundeswirtschaftsminister nicht da in
der debatte war auch nicht da ja kein
ordnungsgemäßer weiter halbmayr
entschuldigung normalerweise
unübersehbar normalerweise unübersehbar
ich nehm das zurück beziehe ich nur
darauf in der debatte nicht sichtbar
er verehrte anwesende meine damen und
herren warum gibt es überhaupt
wissenschaftlicher beiräte wenn man ihr
urteil nicht ernst nimmt und die
regierung ist sowieso besser was erster
ein stockwerk abschaffen
nur es wird belegt mietpreis bremse
funktioniert nicht antwort wir brauchen
sogar einen mieten stoppt diese
fahrverbote beschäftigt die menschen
nicht nur in hessen auch darüber hinaus
seit monaten passiert nichts da sitzen
sie einträchtig nebeneinander
verkehrs und umweltministerin frau
schulze leisten sie doch mal einen
beitrag dazu das problem zu lösen ich
lese von ihnen immer sie wollen die
industrie verpflichten für hardware
nachrüstungen bei den pflicht
nachrüstungen wo manipuliert worden ist
ja aber bei den euro 5 fahrzeuge die
auch von spd verkehrsminister legal in
den betrieb gebracht worden sind da geht
das so einfach nicht also bringen sie
eine andere lösung für das problem denn
die menschen fühlen sich enteignet durch
diese art von politik die sie macht cdu
kann ich kann ja nie auf ausnahmen cdu
jetzt kommt im sommer eine debatte über
das pflicht ja offensichtlich auch kommt
ja aus dem grundsatz prozess der union
offensichtlich auch ein untauglicher
versuch auf das politische klima
einfluss zu nehmen
als ob es so einfach möglich wäre bei
einer jüngeren generation ein ganzes
lebensjahr zu verstaatlichen
als ob das überhaupt in unserer
verfassung vereinbar wäre
als ob das überhaupt mit der regierung
abgestimmt gewesen wäre
dann haben wir die kreuze an behörden
wenden in bayern den rendite stopp von
jens spahn bei auch mittelständischen
gesundheits betrieben
ich habe mal gedacht ist ja bekannt dass
ich in schätze er wolle die nachfolge
von friedrich merz anstreben und jetzt
im amt erfahren wie es ist die nachfolge
von norbert blüm in die er sich begeben
will
also worauf ich hinaus will
und das schlimme ist in der cdu wird ihm
das noch nicht mal schaden das schlimme
ist in der cdu wird ihm das noch nicht
mal schaden meine damen und herren
worauf ich zu sprechen kommen will ist
folgendes da ist eine herausforderung
populismus
wir werden aber diese herausforderung
nicht begegnen wenn die parteien sich
jeweils in ihren politischen positionen
radikalisieren wie mieten stopp oder
zurückgehen in eine vergangenheit wie
pflichtjahr die menschen eher scholz
lassen sich auch mit sozialleistungen
nicht kaufen die menschen wollen von der
regierung nicht ein taschengeld die
menschen erwarten von der regierung
einen plan wie es in deutschland
weitergeht und sie die probleme dieses
landes gelöst werden und das genau
bleiben sie schuldig mitte der
gesellschaft wenn ein staat der die
probleme löst die mitte der gesellschaft
will einen staat der sie im alltag in
ruhe lässt und nicht bremst wenn sie ihr
leben führen wollen der sie aber eben
nicht im stich lässt nicht bei den
großen lebensrisiken und in keiner ecke
an keiner stelle in unserem land zu
keiner zeit und genau diesen anspruch
der menschen wird diese regierung nicht
gerecht
ich komme zum schluss vermerke und sie
unterstreichen was sie zur bedeutung
europas gesagt haben sie haben selbst an
ihrem sommerinterview auch zum ausdruck
gebracht dass sie dereinst insbesondere
wegen ihrer europapolitik
dass sie ihrer kanzlerschaft mit ihrer
europapolitik verbunden sehen wollen da
ist aber jetzt noch einiges zu tun damit
das eine gute bilanz ist denn stand
jetzt ist europa gespalten in ost und
west in der migrationsfrage in nord und
süd in der wirtschafts- und
währungsfragen und auf deutschland wird
es ankommen
diese spaltung zu überwinden aus der
mitte heraus zu führen sich zu
europäischen werten zu bekennen
vielleicht auch eigene positionen in der
migration zu räumen und an anderer
stelle auch flexibilität zu zeigen wenn
es darum geht unter wahrung der
finanzpolitischen eigenverantwortung den
wirtschaftlichen entwicklungsprozess
woanders anzuschieben
heute am tag besteht die gelegenheit
dazu den taten worten den worten taten
folgen zu lassen
im heutigen tag in brüssel und darüber
hinaus bei der aufstellung auch ihrer
parteien in europa im april hat die csu
viktor orban noch zu seinem wahlerfolg
gratuliert
ein wahlerfolg der sich auch gründet auf
eine offen antisemitische kampagne heute
sagt herr orban der italiener salvini
sei sein held zeig mir deine freunde
ich sag dir wer du bist micron hat recht
man kann nicht gleichzeitig für merkel
und für orban sein und deshalb wäre der
wichtigste schritt damit wir europäische
liberalität erhalten dass endlich die
cdu csu einen klaren trennstrich
gegenüber viktor orban und seine anti
liberalen demokratie zu bilder